is it wrong to discriminate against
tenants without a job
how can you how can you have so for
instance a hmo how can you have
professional tenant students
dss you've got to have a market i've got
i know landlords
that they're not they only have dss
templates because that's their market
you know are they are they going to be
are they going to be told off or only
have a dss
i i just think it's stupid you you rent
to who you want to went out to
the problem is it's almost like ruining
a free market
the we have to have a free market we
have to do business with people because
it makes sense for us
our business owners getting more and
more greedy
so i mean i saw i saw a um a really
interesting interview there was a guy
who's a businessman and there was
someone that was having to go in and say
you know you're greedy and
you know you you don't pay your staff
enough okay
fine i i just think straight when
someone says that when someone says you
don't pay your staff enough i'm like
so did they apply for the job and come
for the interview
but they applied for the job came for
the interview got the job
what did they apply for other jobs yeah
probably but they
they probably probably they probably
applied for lots of jobs and they took
my offer because martha was the best
offer
yeah and in the same way i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna simplify it to you in
the same way
no what is they said somebody asked me
pissed me off
okay listen in the same way they're
gonna job hunt
and choose the job that gives them the
offer and the best opportunity guess
what well someone else offers them a job
that's better what they're gonna do
right they want the best deal for them
yes yeah
in the same way i guess what i want as a
business owner the best deal for me
all right that's just called business
it's called a free market
so so in the same in the same way i said
this person
how many how many people do you employ
again oh no none
your boy anybody okay so so when you
book a plumber to come out your house
and fix your toilet
do you call around a bit and get the
best deal you do oh what so you you try
and get the
cheapest person to come and fix your
toilet why don't you use the most
expensive person what's the difference
when i'm hiring staff
you understand people are just messed up
broke
and i think this whole i just this whole
mindset
is broke ass poor and
and and honestly it stinks i don't want
to be around it
what do you think let me know in the
comments below
but i believe the complaining about rich
people
will keep you poor forever
you